tuesday's press conference it featured
ashley solis telling her story
publicly had an impact on many people
specifically
it had an impact on desean watson's
sponsors nike suspended
its relationship with desean watson that
broke yesterday morning jabari young of
cnbc had the news there
beats by dre didn't suspend its
relationship with
sean watson it flat out ended it
and there are a couple of other regional
sponsors reliant
energy which has the naming rights to
the texan stadium and h-e-b which is a
houston business
those relationships are over but
i believe the way the watson camp would
explain it is those relationships were
ending anyway
because he was going to play for another
team they expired after the 2020 season
they weren't going to be renewed
anyway but they clearly won't be now
uh so those aren't as impactful you
i think watson's people would say he
only lost one sponsor
beats by dre nike pressed pause these
other ones weren't going to be
sponsors in the future anyway but
regardless what happened tuesday
spurred action wednesday by people who
paid desean watson money to be
associated with his name
that part of it can't be overlooked
chris no i mean i think this is the tip
of the iceberg i really do i mean i i i
just
again from what we saw on tuesday i'm
expecting that
we're just going to continue to get more
and more news i would think that
as this goes on we might get more and
more women to come forward as far as
publicly putting themselves out there
like we saw
ashley solis do and uh
i would think ultimately it leads to
nike you know going
beyond suspending it and ending their
relationship with watson too
i mean i i don't i don't i'm actually
surprised they didn't end it
there there's there's nothing positive
surrounding and i know we got to let it
all
you know due process let it all play out
and all that but man
it's a bad look and again right you know
forget the sponsors
i'm in the camp right now as i said
yesterday is is the guy gonna play
football again
that's where i'm i'm getting to and
that's where i'm you know
i think that's what he's got to be
worried about more than anything
i had plenty of time to think yesterday
two hour drive up to pittsburgh
for the procedures that i had we'll talk
more about that coming up because i want
to have a
little ps4 button on the fence thank you
very much yes
uh but i had plenty of time to think
yesterday in the car
waiting to have the procedure done uh
the drive home where i was just kind of
half in of it and half out of it my wife
drove me
up and drove me back but um i believe a
couple of things okay that relates to
jean watson yeah the last post that i
that i published yesterday before i left
for pittsburgh for the procedures was
that uh the nfl needs to put deshaun
watson on the commissioner exempt list
now it's not enough to just issue a
statement saying we're deeply disturbed
you need to do something now even though
it's the off-season i
i believe that desean watson
despite everything that we had believed
before this all happened
that he was never going to show up in
houston again i think if he's not put on
the commissioner exemplars before the
starting train
start of training camp i believe he's
going to show up i believe that
eventually
his camp will realize that if this isn't
resolved
and uh he's got two choices
show up and wait for the commissioner's
exemplist and get paid
for 2021 or don't show up and have to
pay fines and forfeit bonus and forfeit
salary potentially
either way you're not playing so if this
is still hovering
in late july despite everything we heard
in january and february
i believe he's going to show up i
believe he has to show it's the right
play
yeah that's the way it's the right play
right you got 10 million dollars
that you're going to earn versus more
than 20 million that you would lose by
sitting out the whole season yeah no
that i mean like that makes a lot of
sense i mean yes that would seem to be
the
the proper way to go you're in trouble
either way
i mean we know that but you might as
well get paid for it if you're if you're
gonna and take advantage of that
you know and yes i mean as you've said
many times it just doesn't seem like
this is not gonna this is not gonna go
away at this point this has got
a lot of time left we're going to be
dealing and talking about this
sporadically for
probably the next seven eight months uh
so that that makes a lot of sense
uh and i could see that happening and
then then the nfl of course will be
forced and the texans will talk to the
nfl
and he will be put on the exemption list
well and
and the texans have to pay him if he's
on the example the only way out of
paying him is to cut him
which they won't want to do because
eventually this will be resolved and
they will want to get something for
him in trade but they will have
ultimately paid him 10 million
this year and his salary in 2022 is 33
million if this happens the linger for
two years and
look it's is it gonna linger for a while
i think it will and i think one of the
realities this is something else i
believe
i believe that tony busby who represents
the 22 women who have sued desean watson
will be very slippery and evasive and
elusive when it comes to trying
to put a settlement value on these cases
now because he's smart enough to realize
there's an imperative now to try to get
these cases settled
definitely desean watson wants to clear
this
away so he can get a trade done before
the draft and my guess here's my guess
this is just a guess my guess is that
busby will hold them at arm's length
be coy be unpredictable uh you know
oh let's try to work something out now i
really don't want to well maybe i do
maybe i don't and then he's going to
swoop in
right around draft time with an offer
that is pretty much take it or leave it
this is how you make this all go away
now
and it opens the door for a potential
trade and if you don't do it we're going
to go forward with these lawsuits i
think something like that is three or
four weeks away i think that's how we
would play it
because it's got look what you
ultimately do and i know it it's kind of
a crass way to think about how justice
is dispensed
but at the end of the day you're just
transacting business
and in the interest of your clients
chris you want to get as much
justice in the form of cash as you can
this is the time to squeeze them not
right now
but in about three weeks as the draft
approaches that's the time to squeeze
and get
maximum make sense compensation for your
clients just let me ask you this i know
we got to go to break but real quick
like okay say that happens right
and he does settle right before the
draft do you like really think
somebody's still going to try to trade
for him right now like
and i think the texans are really going
to want him on his roster if
you know again he does settle and there
he shows up once again
i think if it all gets cleared away
somehow before the draft somehow someway
if it all settles
and part of the settlement is that
there's going to be no criminal charges
and everybody walks away
and they're not even going to cooperate
with the nfl which is a permissible
settlement term if the individuals
involved are willing to agree to that
because the nfl can't force them to talk
yeah i think there's a chance knowing
that he likely gets suspended
to start the season hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports